hi everyone I'm Tony rich and I'm the
executive director here at the st. Louis
chess club we are really excited that we
can officially open the Chess Club
again this Monday June 22nd so we've
implemented lots of important health and
safety measures to make sure everyone
enjoys their time here while staying
safe six feet apart make sure everybody
stays six feet apart social distancing
is very important we also have these
preventative barriers up that you see
behind me for whenever people are
playing across the board members are
also going to be required to wear masks
asked to wear gloves answer a health
screening question when they come in to
make sure that they haven't been exposed
to kovat in addition to that we ask that
anyone who wants to come in and hang out
here at the Chess Club and play to
register to do so so we'll have two hour
blocks where members can come in play
chess against one another and in between
we're gonna disinfect and clean up
everything and make sure that it's safe
again for the next group of people for
more information about what we're doing
here at the club to keep you safe and to
be able to come back and play some chess
check out st. Louis chess club org or
give us a call at three one four three
six one chess